[Music]
the game of thrones epic prequel series
house of the dragon is coming
and many epic characters fitted as well
from targaryens to many other houses
and many other legendary figures from
that time period as well
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
filming begins with the start of 2021
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as show runners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
it's based on georgia martin's and blood
vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic
seat all the way up to the civil war
that nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the yatan
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon the
third's reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons the targaryen
civil war which divided the entire
kingdom
and launched a huge war that was fought
from 129 ac to 131ac
when king viserys died his oldest child
rainer was expected to ascend the iron
throne
since her father did not change the
succession but he had a son aegon
however aegon the second targaryen was
crowned king in the dragonpit
at the quest of alice and hightower the
war between brother and sister would be
known as the dance of the dragons
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons by the time
it was over thousands were dead
the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
by the end of the reign of king viserys
first targaryen 20 dragons were alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid 131 ac
one of the main characters from this
time period was rhaenys targaryen
rhaenyra's right hand princess reign is
targaryen
known among the small folk as the queen
who never was
was the daughter of prince aemon
targaryen and laid the jocelyn baratheon
born in 74 ac
on the seventh day of the seventh month
rhaenys targaryen was the granddaughter
of jaehaerys the first targaryen
and the cousin of israel is the first
targaryen and daemon targaryen
rhaenys was a great beauty she was a
clever capable spirited proud fierce and
fearless woman
she had a fiery temperament rainey swore
steel and copper armor
which flashed on the sun as her father
was the prince of dragonstone
and she was his first born child many
considered her as being next in line for
the iron throne
after her father aemon queen ellis saint
targaryen
then being presented with her
granddaughter called her our queen to be
rhaenys became a dragon rider in 87ac
when she claimed the dragon miley's the
red queen
reigns married legendary coralist of
house valerian
known as the sea snake in 90 ac at the
age of 16.
reynes's father prince aemon targaryen
died in 92ac
azaemon had been the prince of
dragonstone king jaehaerys the first
targaryen had to formally appoint a new
heir to the iron throne
the choice was between rhaenys aemon's
only child and
heir and daemon's brother balon
jaehaerys appointed balon as the new
prince of dragonstone
passing over pregnant rhaenys and her
unborn child
rhaenys herself was the first to object
to the king's decision
and her husband lord corliss velaryon
gave up his position as lord admiral and
his place on the small council
following that rhaenys and her husband
returned to driftmark
others angered by the king's decision
included rhaenys's mother
lady jocelyn baratheon her uncle lord
bormund baratheon
and her grandmother king jaehaerys's
wife queen eliza targaryen
rhaenys gave birth to her first child a
daughter she named lena valerian
late in the year 92ac the following year
she gave birth to a son
elaine or valerian although both house
valerian and house baratheon insisted
that laenor had the better claim to the
throne
prince balon remained king jaehaerys as
heir when balon died in 101ac
king jaehaerys called the first great
council at harrenhal
to decide the matter of succession
fourteen claims were considered
including the claims of rhaenys and her
children reigney's
uncle lord bormund baratheon was
outspoken in supporting the claims of
rainey center's son lenore
during the great council and lord ellard
stark gave his support to rhaenys and
corliss as well
other supporters included house dustin
of barrington
and house manderly of white harbor yet
the claims of rhaenys and her daughter
were rejected
on account that they are females rhaenys
and coralists use their wealth and
influence
to persuade the lord's present to vote
for their son lenore
one of the two primary claimants for
this they received support from lord
bormund
lord ellard lord manderly lord dustin
lord blackwood lord bar
emman lord celtigare as well as others
however lanar was eventually passed over
in favor of balon's son viserys
while the vote was kept secret it was
rumored the assembled lords favored
viserys by 20 to 1
for having been passed over in the line
of succession once again
the court the jester mushroom would name
her the queen who never was
following the death of queen emma aaron
in 105 ac
grand maze to run cider suggested to
king viserys the first targaryen
that he shall take reinis's 12 year old
daughter lena to wife
king viserys however chose alice and
hightower
angered by the third time she and her
family had been scorned by house
targaryen
rhaenys and her family did not attend
the royal wedding in 106 ac
in 113 ac king viserys the first and his
small council began discussions
concerning a betrothal for princess
rhaenyra targaryen
viserys is heir they eventually agreed
on reyness's son lenore
rhaenyra and lenore were vetted the next
year
reynes's daughter laina was married to
daemon targaryen
the rogue prince both of rhaenys's
children died in 120 ac
lena died in childbirth during the early
days of the year
valenor was killed by circuarl corey
while attending a fair in spicetown
when the dance of the dragons began in
129 ac princess rain is set on the black
council of queen rhaenyra targaryen
the daughter of the late king viserys
the first targaryen when the valyrian
fleet closed off the galette
sailing fourth from dragonstone and
driftmark to block all shipping for
blackwater bay
the black's plan was for reigns to fly
overhead on melees
to keep the greens from attacking their
ships with dragons
the news arrived in dragonstone about
the death of lucero solarian at the
hands of prince eamon targaryen
reinis and her husband prevented
lucifer's brother joffrey from mounting
his dragon to avenge his brother
grief stricken following the death of
luceries queen rhaenyra targaryen gave
reinies and corliss command over her war
council
when rook's rest was attacked by sir
kristen cole and the greens
as aegon the second supporters were
called rhaenyra sent her aunt to burn
the army and save the fort
mounted on her dragon melees reign is
unexpectedly turned up at rook's nest
and laid ways to the enemy
army however rhaenys was flying into a
trap
her nephew aemond targaryen confronted
her on his monstrous dragon vegar
the last of the original three targaryen
dragons that conquered westeros
along with the king himself on his
magnificent dragon sunfire
despite being outnumbered rhaenys did
not flee
reign is turned to meet the attack
despite the knowledge that melee stood
no chance against the two dragons
militia's flame faced vegars and
sunfires
until it looked like that there was a
second sun in the sky
the three dragons attacked each other
and fell to the ground entangled
by the time the fight was over eamond
and vogar were the only ones
uninjured malagun had to have a constant
dose of milk of the poppy to survive
and sunfire who laid on top of aegon was
wounded
and the vein almost completely torn off
it was crippled and would never fly
again
milis had been torn to shreds and
rhaenys was just ash and bone
that was reis's brave last stand where
she died for a nearest cause
reinis's husband correlates the sea
snake was enraged that reiner had sent
his wife reigns to the battle alone
rather than going herself or ordering
her sons to accompany rhaenys
beloved daughter of lady jocelyn
baratheon and prince aemon targaryen
faithful wife of lord corliss valerian
mother and grandmother
the queen who never was lived fearlessly
and died amidst blood and fire
she was 55 years old it's how gildane
describes her in fire and blood
reigning targaryen will definitely be
one of my favorite characters in the
house of the dragon
fierce and smart woman brave and loyal
honorable woman hope holds her oath to
queen rhaenyra and who fought for her
cause
so fearfully that not even vegard and
sunfire combined could fear her away
legendary characters such as reigning
targaryen legendary battles such as the
siege of the rook's rest in which
reinies flew her dragon the red queen
straight into aegon and amend
despite being outnumbered by their two
dragons out of which one was mighty
vagar
reinis couldn't fled but she chose to
fight and then down in epic battle in
fire and blood
all of that and more this game of
thrones prequel show house of the dragon
brings in 2022
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace